[Applause]
Illinois in the US Congress and a South
challenging Donald Trump for the 2020
Republican President nomination joe
walsh
[Applause]
[Music]
okay you are challenging Donald Trump
for the Republican nomination but
apparently they don't know your history
jobs but some bad news for you today
South Carolina Nevada Arizona and Kansas
say they will not even allow a primary
challenger that why are they so insecure
I thought Donald Trump was 90% popular
in the Republican Party they can't even
have a primary challenger who's gonna
lose you're gonna lose not necessarily
well you're not gonna take the
nomination away from Trump oh I've got a
shot
oh absolutely bill look would think
about that we are not North Korea we're
not Russia think about what Trump did
today Trump wants to eliminate elections
he told South Carolina Arizona Nevada
and Kansas no primary elections you talk
about undemocratic [ __ ] and this is
coming from all right but see you are
doing something different there's a few
people who are challenging Donald Trump
bill weld I think is doing it right I
mean who else who are the people that's
it right now okay but a few others are
things I'm thinking about it you're the
only one from the right yes but I want
to ask you this you know you don't like
Trump for a lot of the reasons that
we've been talking about here in a long
time you don't like that he lies I don't
like that he's a traitor stuff like that
little things but issue wise what about
the judges you like that right he's done
some good things let's just go down the
list and see how much in line you so the
judges say abortion judge is here for
that good conservative judge okay just
go with me Joe
pipelines you for that you might plan
guys I've seen your record the above all
the okay drilling in Alaska think about
it think about it Joe you're enough
trial you were here's Hill here's what
Joe you were a leader of the anti Obama
nutcase caucus yes okay I helped lead to
Trump look at Rome I helped put it's
true right now I helped good to my
Renard and yourself like that yes hey
Bill two things led to Trump a weak
feckless Republican party that was out
of touch with where their voters were in
people like me who let our rhetoric get
ahead of us but I'm back there pulling
my hair out because this thing has
nothing to do with issues Donald Trump
is a horrible human being
period I'm against tariffs is not about
issues but Trump's unfit again if you
were to beat him and be the president
it's a lot a lot of things on this list
they would not like and I just Obamacare
you were for that not really no no no
rolling back dodd-frank yeah for that
the tax cuts for the rich you like that
class o publican right exactly the power
to the EPA I mean I could go down the
list so I'm just saying here's the point
here's the point and Matt said it I am a
Republican I'm a conservative Republican
I do not in will not lie every time I
open my mouth right and also I will not
only put my interest I mean this is like
bizarro world because we for the first
time in our history bill we have a
president who lies virtually every time
he talks and we have a president
incapable of thinking about anybody but
himself and you saw that there hurricane
this week I mean he's incapable of
thinking about this country okay I'm
just sayin you would not know
you would not lie but you would also
would get rid of the Endangered Species
Act like he did okay I'm just saying but
Joe I remember you when you were in
Congress you were part of that tea party
group and just now I know you've had to
answer a lot of questions about race
okay okay you know you did you admit it
also you know you said you sent out four
thousand tweets some of them were racist
but you're not a racist yes a fine
distinction but let's move on but
general all bias were all prejudice and
sometimes we all step in it and I must
have didn't looks me in the eye okay no
not like that
[Laughter]
haven't used all the power of just look
me in the eye and tell me that the
seething frothing hatred that I
remembered that you had for Barack Obama
had nothing to do with the fact that he
was black on the first no gosh no absent
bill no no again nothing to do with that
no no no look his policies now again
oftentimes myself and people like me I
mean we went to Washington the Tea Party
to do something about the debt but yeah
that what you do
it's not a political party you feel that
that like a little little correctness
and God work party carry wheels fine
that's the thing we're Don Quixote okay
so do you sometimes wish you were the
other joe walsh
[Applause]
written funk 49 and midnight man and
Pretty Maids he's a tough he's he's
still living they're out on tour that
Vegas you know they're doing [ __ ]
awesome no he's the guy who wrote life's
been good to me
the guy whose have to defend yourself
against okay so my last question is you
say Donal you know you voted for Trump
yes you even said I'm voting for him on
election day if he loses I'm grabbing my
musket yeah I'm gonna let you go on that
one because musket we don't have muskets
anymore yes so I'm gonna give you that
one and say you are being metaphorical
yes still not a good thing to put out
the idea that if the election doesn't go
our way we reach for guns would you
allow that yes but great bill not a good
idea it's still the idea of I don't like
the election get a gun
no I I know but you're talking about I
had a client I'm gonna give you that one
get that but you you said you know now
you've turned so Trump basically Kondo
he's a con man he is a con man so you
were forum tell us why we should vote
for you if it took you until 2019 to
know that Donald Trump was full of [ __ ]
well it didn't severe questions a good
class a request to good question okay
that's right and it didn't take till
2019 for the record 18 last year yeah
[Laughter]
[Applause]
and Helsinki that was it when he stood
in yeah the world and said I'm with
Putin and I'm okay that's a good place
okay we okay we want people right who've
found the religion yes they do and we
want you Joe we want you we do okay so
but okay so Trump you didn't get that
now you see your area of your ways
what about global warming you were
always a denier what do you think sit
here three years from now and have you
go [ __ ] I messed up on that one not a
denier and the Republican Party needs to
wake up
I'm telling you this right now wake up
an early knowledge yes that it's an
issue and it's a problem
Republicans gotta be part of this debate
they've got to acknowledge that it's a
real issue
baby steps powder it's that one
you